the Joe Rogan experience the other thing
I was thinking of in terms of martial
arts is that I know you have a
background in martial arts a grappling
martial arts judo yeah that wouldn't be
so good for that unless you had some
sort of a working dummy that was
programmed that I think could be
possible yeah I actually made a pitch
that what I would like to see from a
martial arts standpoint there is
immersive instructionals yes the I'm
when you set up the modern cameras right
for the 180 stereo I am VR it does give
you this extra sense of depth that for a
lot of things if you're looking at
instructional sometimes it's a little
hard to see exactly where the hands are
in the different areas and I think that
there's some value for a lot of training
aspects for virtual reality in fact
that's like Walmart's you doing a ton of
work with that and there are a lot of
companies that I'm one of the side
effects of that of putting a VR headset
on is you are forced to pay attention
where if you're a company like Walmart
training people you expect most people
wind up having their phone out they're
not paying attention but put them inside
the headset they have it's almost the
Clockwork Orange stretching in the eyes
up they have no choice but to pay
attention but if it's important and
you're training them for something that
matters this is you know what you want
but when I was thinking about things
like I am I am like I remember watching
some judo instructionals for things and
like male Olympian level stuff it just
goes by so fast you just blink and it's
gone I but a lot of things that I did in
VR for some of the video stuff was
giving you this almost superpower sense
of time where you freeze-frame and then
being able to like slowly frame forward
frame back jog forward and when you've
got an immersive sense here that really
feels like an interesting godlike power
like you're sitting here you're just
like stop time step step step
roll back look closely at it you know
run forward and almost anything physical
that you want to train people to do is
gonna have some benefits for things like
that and that's something that we're
we're still just really at the early
days of exploring that for making a
difference for people's training yeah I
think sparring you could have something
that would throw strikes at you and you
could move away from those strikes and
hit it
leg kick it do things
along those lines the problem would be
that you're not hitting anything it's
the only problem yeah but there's
certainly some valuable things you could
do there and I have a friend that has a
stick fighting background when I showed
him beat saver he was like Oh
immediately you have to do some stick
training thing for this and yeah clearly
we're even if you're not hitting things
there but that sense of getting the
motion figuring out how to move around
the situational awareness and there's
probably some things to do there it is a
stretch to imagine some kind of a head
mounted display involved in actual
grappling in any way but I that's the
big stretch yeah because also you would
have the thing the only thing I was
thinking is you could have like a dummy
like a robot mechanized dummy that has
crude movement like but but it does
understand it can throw punches and
kicks and it's programmed and you could
kind of spar with this thing in a
virtual world and that thing also
connects to the system so it understands
where you are and understands what
you're doing arts robots punching yes
that could go poorly go very poorly yeah
I could go very poor but it could also
be awesome but you could imagine perhaps
again the augmented reality systems that
we have today are finding most of their
value in training and it's for people
like jet engine mechanics but you could
imagine scenarios like that where you're
training something like martial arts or
it's looking through and it's not making
you a fully simulated thing but even if
you're working through a drill with
someone if it's basically drawing the
outline of your arm goes here your leg
goes over here I am again
training is one of the value areas that
is working out yeah visualization is
very important in martial arts I mean
shadow boxing is already a huge part of
strikers learning like learning how to
visualize and that's what they're doing
that's what they're supposed to do and
when you see a good fighter shadow
boxing they're sort of recreating these
movements have you had a virtual reality
headset and you had an actual opponent
in front of you I think it would be way
more lifelike and actually way more
beneficial in fact there are a bunch of
football teams that are using VR for
some of their training which largely is
kind of visualizing the way plays are
going to go it's not like they have
virtual versions of everything but that
sense of being able to get it to see
what it would look like when it's going
right
kind of lock it into your mind it has
some value it seems to me that something
like the void which is really fun to do
you could see in the future as
technology improves having quake like
competitions in some sort of enormous
warehouse environment with other players
that's been one of the real visions from
from early days and in fact last year we
we cobbled together a demo at oculus
connect our big eye kind of convention
which is next in the new ones next month
here but we had a large area set up and
you had this game called dead and buried
which is kind of a cowboy zombie
shooting thing but we had a bunch of
people that could play in one common
enormous shared area and it was
amazingly cool and everybody's like well
when do we get to play with this and
this was all held together with duct
tape sort of experience that's a lot of
hard work to turn it real but this
warehouse scale stuff there are a number
of companies that are trying to do this
with various bits of technology yeah
just pulled something yeah that idea of
that was I you know where you could set
up people are crouching behind real
things in their virtual headset this is
all kind of zombie western themed stuff
and they can put their hand on real
things there they can move around draw a
bead on people and then you've got
another person there what with a tablet
which is a window into the virtual world
so they could look at that and see the
whole the way it's all drawn in style
the way the people are rendered inside
it so there is yeah this is again the
amazing stuff you can do outside of your
home where you get the VR stuff that you
wind up doing inside your home and then
you figure out what things can you do if
you're willing to set up a dedicated
play space and yeah this is people not
moving around too much it's mostly kind
of a cover based thing but there are
companies that have people kind of
charging around in pads I am you know
with a virtual world that they can skin
in all sorts of different ways and
that's it's all exciting and as so
here's we're getting an image of what it
looks like to the people that are
playing it so and as things get more and
more accurate in terms of what you're
seeing and more realistic you could
conceivably be jumping up and down on
boxes and running up ladders and things
along those lines and actually doing it
in the virtual world as well as in the
real world yeah so right now like if
you've done the void you can tell
there's like a little gap between
reality
you wouldn't want to do like a diving
grab at a ladder rung but you know it's
you can see that there are things we
need to fix to get there but that's all
possible there's no can't be done sort
of thing there and eventually you won't
even need to be holding a controller
it'll be able to track your whole body
just from cameras and work all the kind
of computer vision magic out from that
and you will then be able to set up
these wonderful skinned virtual
environments yeah that's why I was
thinking like eSports in terms of like
an actual sport sport like eSports in
terms of like doing something on a
soccer field with a bunch of people with
virtual reality and they're playing some
sort of horrific nightmare dystopian
environment zombie game like whatever
you know fill in the blank with your
imagination yeah that's totally gonna be
here Wow
that's how far away away from that so a
lot of it depends on kind of company
plans where we don't have people pester
us about the the technical hooks for
things like this and the people that are
doing it themselves like the void they
put their own tracking technology on top
of it because ours isn't set up publicly
in a way that they can do that so it's a
lot of work for people to do it we will
eventually commercialize it so that you
can set things up more easily out of the
box I am but a lot of these then become
entrepreneurial business plans I'm like
okay who's gonna go raise the the tens
of millions of dollars to set up and do
it right but it's on the cusp of being
it's not a technical problem now it's
not a technical impossibility no new
research really needs to be done but
there's still lots of challenges to work
out so it's more about figuring out if
you can get the business plan to close
you can make the technology work